what about if I touch my mouth and I've
got it and then I put my hand on a
doorknob or something how long can it
live on a doorknob yeah you can live a
week a we yeah that's a long time yeah
it's up to a week it depends on certain
things like temperature and humidity it
degrades faster in in hot warmer and
more humid air but at the same time you
know we're not like singapore happen
epidemic you singapore 70 75 degrees you
know that's like 20 25 degrees celsius
and so that still happened but that
these were mostly indoor people
singapore epidemic happened the super
spreading event was at a Grand Hyatt
Hotel Singapore in that hotel
you know hotels it doesn't really matter
what the outside climate is right if you
had an indoor conference center or
indoor gym and you get it it doesn't
matter what it is outside so you know I
think that one of the misinformation
actually is about oh it's gonna all go
away when the summer comes it's gonna be
too hot except we are indoor workplace
kind of people and there's something
called the southern hemisphere the earth
and then it'll just go to in Africa and
Australia and you know Indonesia and
when this is wintertime that in the
north in the summertime in north and
wintertime and south so I don't think
that it's gonna go away in the summer
arguments you might slow down a little
but it could easily come back in the
fall oh that's that's the tricky part
the the virus things is these survivor
basically can containment work or we
just passed the stuff um containment you
know a lot of people say w chose still
trying to be optimistic the containment
can work but I think I think we we have
may have to move from containment to
mitigation
now you do that what's the difference
mitigation is just you know reducing the
number of people who are exposed
and no and you know you test as much as
you can but in terms of actually
stopping the virus you just you mitigate
its impact and you mitigate its spread
but containment just means preventing a
community transmission event right
someone is someone trapped travels from
say Iran lands are the airport and then
they we detect that they're sick and we
quarantine them then that is contained
right but if they can't come back goat
send infect sir kids goes a daycare
childcare goes to a party infects
everyone and they all go home and they
all test positive and they all don't
know necessarily where they had gotten
it it's not contain any more its
community transmission and community
transmission is way more dangerous than
a travel related thing because it means
they picked it up randomly in the
community of an unknown source that we
can't necessarily trace anymore
[Music]
you